foreign
Texas hi Nate welcome to the Ramsay show
appreciate it sure what's up
so I'm trying to find out I have about
12 years of trying to convince my wife
to let me buy a flip house finally
convince her after saving up about fifty
thousand dollars to do so and she didn't
want to do it but she made me promise I
wouldn't uh try to rent it out that we
would sell it at the end of it after a
three-month construction duration That
was supposed to be this was this was
back in November of 21 I bought it and
we're now a year and a half later that
three months has turned into a year and
a half
and finally after three three
contractors got the house finished and
put it on the market in April and it's
been on the market for a little over 60
days now with uh showing or two every
other week or every week and no offers
anything like that I've got the price
from 240 down to 217 and still not
seeing much more movement so this is
harder than they say on Tick Tock huh
much harder with the residential
contractors there's a different
different how much have you lost all the
idiots on Tick Tock have to use
residential contractors too
yeah yeah
I got 57 million dollars in 20 minutes
and a bunch of crap okay
sorry Nate I've been right where you are
and it ain't no fun
let's go ahead I'm sorry no no I want to
know how much he's lost no he hadn't
lost anything yet he's not sold it he
hadn't sold it correct I still still
have it and haven't sold it yet and and
do you have a mortgage on that property
so I have a HELOC on my my personal
property my my own home and I've paid
for paid cash for the rest of it so I've
got 157
000 in the HELOC that I owe and then the
rest was paid in cash and I'm I'm in it
to at 221 right now so I'm estimating
with realtor fees and closing costs
it'll be about 241 that I'll be all in
but you're on the market for 217.
correct so you're going to lose money
yeah
definitely gonna lose money for sure
okay all right and because you've missed
you messed your estimates up uh and your
contractor choices up and so your
construction cost was way above what you
originally planned in your pro forma
well no my profile actually was uh 2 27
was what I was estimating to get then
the market went way up and then it went
way down and while I didn't go way down
but it's for some reason it's just not
selling the house there's a house three
three-story or three houses down that's
selling for 260 and it's it's on the
market for 260 and it's 200 square feet
less than this one so why why has
Insurance you should be giving yours
away at 217 why are people not crawling
all over it the Austin Market's not that
dead is the work is the workmanship not
good
well it's it's about an hour outside in
Boston it's not in Austin
um if the house down the street is worth
260 and you have yours at 200 square
feet Less on the mark 200 square feet
more on the market for 217. someone
should have snapped yours up in a
heartbeat
I would have thought the same thing my
realtor said that the the comps when we
were going through this was between 217
and 238 is what the comps were other
realtors that have come through said
it's a great price point at 225 and and
now I've dropped it down even more so I
don't know why it's not selling but I'm
trying to figure out if at this point do
I I've got about 50
000 in cash that's not gonna or in
Investments that are not going to have a
penalty if I take it out I'm trying to
figure out do I pay down the HELOC and
just
uh wait wait it out or the HELOC is
independent of this decision it's on
your home
you could sell this house for ten
dollars and you still got the HELOC
well I would tell you I would uh yeah
I'm just saying the interest rate in
your mind only are they connected well
he's just trying to think I don't want
to lose more money on interest having
this loan sit around I know correct okay
so the the all right number one you need
to get um jump online at Ramsey
Solutions and get in touch with a Ramsay
trusted endorsed local provider real
estate agent have them come out and look
at it because there's someone that's
going to have at least three years of
experience and they will have moved
hundreds of units not tens of units and
they will be able to give you some
insight and you may want to change real
estate agents again
um so first thing because the numbers
you're giving me don't make sense I
agree you the the a house does not vary
as much as it has in this conversation
and value why have they given you any
what you would call negative feedback as
to why why there's the variance there or
why it hasn't sold
so she's still saying that we're we're
within the right range and the only
there isn't anything like the house
looks good there's no concerns about the
house itself the neighborhood is up and
coming there's a lot of new builds the
house that's 260 was a new build mine
was a renovation
um so that's a little bit of a
difference yeah they're not it's not a
little bit of a difference it's a
completely different product they're not
comparable
you wouldn't use a new build as a comp
for a renovated old house they're not
comps well it's their earlier comparison
doesn't even hold water so it's about a
bad analysis okay so yeah I I think you
need to get some help and look uh truly
go to Ramsey Solutions and check out
Ramsey trusted person have them look at
it this is what I would personally do
and then based on what they're telling
me I'm I'm either going to change
Realtors and or I'm going to drop the
price when you pay down the HELOC you
can do that in three months four months
five months if you need to or you can
sell this house I'm Gonna Keep lowering
this house I mean if you got to drop it
at 195 and get it gone get it gone
because here's the thing you have gone
to the school of life and you are paying
some stupid tuition
okay you did not analyze or understand
the marketplace for contractors you do
not know how to hire or manage
contractors you do not know how to run a
pro forma on a flip
because you didn't have any margin in
your flip your flip needed to have
another 25 margin that had you paid too
much for this thing going in considering
the amount of work you had to do to it
because your your margin after you sell
it is not anything you're not making
spit if your contractors had worked well
it wouldn't make spit and so you've got
to go back through and do an autopsy on
why this deal failed where you failed in
the process since you're going to pay 40
or 50 000 for this lesson learn the
lesson in detail and the most painful
lesson of all
is his wife gonna say I told you so so I
told you don't do this so you did not
put proper evaluation on the house you
underestimated the cost and you
underestimated how hard it was to deal
with contractors and you underestimate
the time it was going to take to flip it
and you underestimate that you were
going to continue to be in a white hot
Market that's three things I can tell
right now you didn't know the value you
thought you did you didn't know the heat
of the market and you thought you did
and you don't know how to deal with
contractors and you thought you did and
you missed your estimates on your
construction and you thought you did
those four things combined are going to
cost you 30 or 40 000 before you're done
if you're lucky only that but either way
sell the thing get rid of it dump you
can pay off the home equity loan then
it's just a matter of how much of your
cash you're going to lose you're going
to net 150 so your home equity loan is
gone it's just a matter of how much your
cash you're going to lose then the last
piece of this is this
I used to do crap like you did
only I did it to the tune of about four
million dollars worth and it caused me
to go bankrupt Nate that's why I got no
patience for it because I just exactly
only I was successful at flipping them
and making a profit but I had a lot of
short-term notes and the banks called my
notes I was 28 years old and bankrupted
me 30 years ago so I've learned my
lesson on doing flips with anything but
cash and I don't listen to people like
Tic Tac people that are doing real
estate seminars either I'm done with it
so those are the things I learned the
last one is this proverbs 31 says who
can find a virtuous wife for the heart
of her husband before she is she is more
valuable than rubies
for the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have no lack of
gain I don't do crap like this when my
wife doesn't feel good about it it costs
me money every time I do
[Music]